hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel about how to
survive in the online jungle now first i
want to ask you a pretty simple question
have you been to the movies lately and
i'm talking about the whole setup the
big screen popcorn and surround sound
well look first the pandemic then the
streaming services that became an
integral part of our routine seriously
reduced the income of hollywood studios
but i want to talk to you about an
income stream of the film industry that
is
unrelated to the sale of tickets or the
sale of films via the internet i'm
actually interested in how financial
fraudsters can use the dream factory of
hollywood for financial crimes and i'll
start with
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i'm going to start the story with the
film in which this word was used exactly
569 times and yet this didn't prevent
the filmmakers from receiving five oscar
nominations have you guessed which one
this was yet well yes it's the wolf of
wall street
of course i'm sure that you've heard of
this film the brilliant dicaprio in the
role of a charming fordster in the
director's chair right we've all heard
of it and watched it the script was
actually based on the autobiography of
jordan belford a new york broker and
also money laundering specialist so
what could go wrong i mean the film was
a success right worldwide it bought in
about 400 million dollars despite the
fact that it cost the creators only 100
million
but hold on a minute
it turns out that this film cost roughly
half of james cameron's titanic and okay
the zlitzang was released in 1997 and
the dollar was worth more than that it
is now but also in 2013 another film
featuring dicaprio appeared on screens
the great gatsby cost the creator's only
five million dollars for it is filled
with
a variety of different complex computer
effects and also luxurious costumes so
what did the money really go towards in
the film adaptation of the memoirs of a
financial fraudster
i mean maybe the drugs in the frame were
real right
of course not the drugs in the scenes
were fake but the scammers behind the
scenes were real
let's go back to 2007 where the story of
this film first began
no one wanted to invest in the script
and a significant part of it was vivid
description of financial crimes and the
rest of the time was occupied by parties
with drugs naked women and alcohol
nobody was interested in this
in 2012 the company red granite pictures
found 100 million dollars for filming
this production company was famous for
its luxurious office on sunset boulevard
it contained unique cinematic artifacts
such as a poster from the premiere of
the film metropolis by franz lang which
was in itself worth a million dollars
unfortunately the company's own
successes were not at all impressive by
that time it released only one film
friends with kids a simple romantic
comedy that grossed just about 13
million at the box office
there was also another film in the works
the crime drama out of the furnace with
a budget of 22 million but that movie
flopped at the box office and collected
less than 15 million so how did such an
inexperienced company manage to find 100
million dollars for a risky production
about the wolf of wall street well it's
all about the identity of the founders
red granite pictures was founded by a
businessman from kentucky joey mcfarland
and the stepson the prime minister of
malaysia riza aziz now they were brought
together by another malay businessman
joe lowe
low became the key individual in the
whole story he was born into a wealthy
family who did business in mining and
also alcohol trading he studied in
london where he made acquaintance with a
whole load of influential families and
then he started investing in particular
he actively participated in the affairs
of the malaysian sovereign wealth fund
or 1 mdb
officially he was never on the board of
directors of 1mdb but later american
investigators would find evidence that
lowe was involved in many of the fund's
key transactions and more specifically
the financing of the production company
red granite pictures low knew many
celebrities throughout the world of show
business he presented kim kardashian
with a white ferrari as a wedding gift
right for instance he spent more than
eight million dollars on jewelry for the
victoria's secret model miranda care and
what works by picasso for leonardo
dicaprio
low hosted these incredible parties and
he effectively underneath asian gatsby
doesn't all of this sound a lot like the
story of the brilliant wine connoisseur
rudy kenyawan who i spoke about in the
video about money laundering via luxury
goods
well in this case the fairy tale also
didn't last very long
by 2014 the first pieces of evidence
were appearing that low was involved in
schemes of embezzlement of significant
amounts of money from one mdb
in 2016 police confiscated the
properties of the asian tycoon and
celebrities began returning their
expensive gifts can you believe that and
soon red granite pictures was also
charged with financial fraud the
production company decided to
acknowledge the accusation of the us
government and admitted that its
activities were illegally financed by
the 1mdb funds well this confession cost
the company a whopping 60 million
dollars in fines and this was a serious
blow to the company's reputation
and since 2017 it hasn't released a
single film
however you need to understand that low
laundered relatively small amounts
through films participating in red
granite pictures was a great way to
provide access to say some of
hollywood's most famous actors and
directors but the main flow of dirty
money was through real estate channels
experts from the department of justice
have suggested that low took part in a
disappearance of at least two billion
dollars
every year more and more evidence of
asian gatsby's financial crimes
materializes
however we're unlikely to get any
answers from him for many years now he's
been hiding out somewhere in asia he's
said to have been seen in macau china
but the chinese authorities reject all
accusations of harboring low but anyway
back to dirty filmmaking because this is
what we're focusing on very dirty
filmmaking
have you ever heard of the movie deep
throat
well i hope you're at least 18 years old
otherwise i'm probably going to have to
ask you to watch one of their other
videos maybe the one about how real
hackers differ from the ones in movies
and tv series right there's a link to
that one in the video description it's
quite good but look if you are over the
age of 18 let's continue
now the plot of this movie could only
take place in new york and only in the
crazy 70s in those days the big apple
was ruled by five mafia clans or
families
surely you're familiar with the movie
the godfather right with marlon brando
and al pacino so the model for their
protagonists were real criminal families
just in the movies they changed their
surnames little so that's why the real
corleones were called banano the
gambinos were hiding behind the name
natalia and the heroes of our story
actually had the same name colombo not
cuneo in 1972 a member of the colombo
clan named louis bucci perena invested
22 and a half thousand dollars in
shooting a porn movie
now in those days it was quite a
profitable and respectable business to
be in the films were shot on amateur
film cameras and played in underground
cinemas
richer americans could actually order
copies of the films and arrange a
private viewing
deep throat could have remained one of
dozens of similar pawn films if the
impossible hadn't happened
the colombo family took advantage of the
bureaucratic delays and delayed the
procedure for assigning age ratings
thanks to this prano managed to show the
film in ordinary commercial cinemas its
success was overwhelming huge queues
formed outside the box office and
celebrities were spotted among the first
in the audience for example actor jack
nicholson and the author of breakfast at
tiffany's truman capote a review of the
film appeared even in the very
conservative new york times the hype was
incredible but it's the film's revenue
that's really interesting here according
to the director deep throat earned 600
million dollars at the box office now
this can't be anything but alarming in
1970 about 203 million people lived in
the united states a movie ticket cost
about two and a half dollars turns out
that deep throat was watched by every
single inhabitant of the country
including babies young girls priests
mormons and the blind tell me your
secret or i killed you
despite the fact that at most the film
was shown in only half of the states how
could such an incredible sum of money be
explained well the colombo family may
well have taken advantage of the
popularity of the film to legalize their
criminal proceeds it was easy enough to
negotiate with the owners of cinemas and
sell themselves huge numbers of tickets
right and then return the money to
yourself as the creator of the most
profitable movie in history
of course this is
you know impossible to prove after so
many years but the scheme is quite
plausible in the 70s another fraud
scheme related to film production
flourished in new york an aspiring
director and screenwriter dan gordon was
involved in a similar story in 1971 he
began filming for the movie potluck the
budget was about 100 thousand dollars
which is provided by one of the mafia
families and gordon shot illegally on
the streets of new york he worked
constantly on script edits to meet
deadlines and budget restrictions but
this didn't garner much enthusiasm at
all among investors on the contrary as
the filming neared its end the
relationship between the director and
the family representatives was only
worsening
gordon couldn't figure out what was
going on until he found out the terrible
truth
according to accounting documents a
whole million dollars was invested in
this film the mafia had hoped that the
young director would not be able to cope
and that the film would be declared as
unfinished of course in this case all
the fake investments would have landed
in the pockets of the criminal producers
gordon was deeply frightened by this
discovery and ran away from new york at
the first opportunity
he actually served as an officer in the
israeli armed forces for almost 10 years
and only actually returned to america in
the early 80s fortunately the potluck
story had already been forgotten by that
time gordon eventually returned to
screenwriting and actually went down in
hollywood history as the author of
passenger 57 hurricane and rambo the
last blood so although in this case dan
gordon did not agree to working for the
mafia the history of cinema knows the
name of a director who was proud of
helping companies evade taxes if you're
a fan of computer games such as alone in
the dark postal or far cry then you
probably already know who we're talking
about so meet the winner of the golden
raspberry 2009 in the domination for
worst director of the year ue bowl
unsuccessful films happened to all
directors but only uebol managed to have
such an absolute lack of box office
receipts let's take a look now in 2003
he shot house of the dead with a budget
of 12 million dollars but the film
barely collected 13. two years later
alone in the dark is released which cost
say 20 million but collected only half
of this amount
in 2007 in the name of a king a dungeon
siege tale appeared on screens the
budget of this dark fantasy grew to 60
million dollars and yet it collects just
13 million at the box office
now it appears that the budget is
growing and yet revenue remains at the
same level
would you invest your own money in films
by such an unsuccessful director well
yes you would if you worked in germany
and you were trying to dodge high taxes
the secret here lies in the desire of
the german government to create its own
film industry if german companies
invested their money in the film
industry then that money wouldn't be
taxed whatsoever moreover in the event
of a financial failure of the resulting
film the state will compensate for part
or all of the funds spent now do you
understand how much of a neat scheme
this actually turns out to be instead of
paying your taxes you invest money in
the work of a weak director he returns a
significant part of these funds through
your own offshore company or spends on
say intangible services of other
companies and with the remaining money
he makes a bad film that flops at the
box office in the state then compensates
you for your unsuccessful investments
now for you everything's in the black
but not for the government in fact ue
bowl is not a unique phenomenon in
cinema hollywood studios have also been
taking advantage of the shortcomings of
german legislation for years do you
remember another film adaptation of a
game tomb raider with angelina jolie as
laura croft simon west's film cannot be
compared to the creations of uebol
that's for sure with a production of 94
million dollars and at the box office
the film raked in almost 300 million
dollars you can't exactly call it a
failure but bowls films are combined
with tax-exempt funding schemes american
journalist edward j epstein estimated
that the direct costs of paramount for
the production of tomb raider was only
seven million dollars so how is that all
possible well actually it's all about
tax legislation epstein gives the
following figures at first in order to
take advantage of the benefits the
american company solved the film that
hadn't actually been shot yet for 94
million dollars to the german company
the newcom group the german company
immediately signed the counter lease
agreement with the americans for 83
million
so as you can see filming hasn't even
begun and paramount has already acquired
more than 10 million
oh my god
the company actually repeated a similar
deal with english partners although
actually in order for that to take
effect it was necessary to shoot i think
several scenes in the uk but this saved
them a further 12 million dollars the
company compensated for the remaining 65
by pre-selling the rights to rent the
future film in countries where the game
about lara was particularly successful
so distributors from japan spain france
italy and of course germany and england
joined the project that's all the studio
had to find less than 10 million to
shoot a blockbuster based on a popular
game with one of hollywood's biggest
stars in the title role this is really a
win-win situation of course such a tax
haven could not last too long the first
the german government blocked benefits
to foreign companies and then it came to
ua bowl's german colleagues the maestro
of appalling film adaptations himself
stopped making films in 2016. they say
that he tried to produce other people's
work but he quickly got tired of it now
ball is enjoying a well-earned rest
according to the net worth portal his
wealth is estimated to 10 million
dollars
not bad at all for a man who hasn't made
a single profitable movie in his
lifetime
i think you'd be pretty naive to think
that government officials and aml
specialists are not aware of all of
these stories the names of uebol louis
parano and joe lowe are very familiar to
any expert in the sphere of combating
financial fraud
but this doesn't mean that scammers are
idly sitting about
they're constantly looking for more and
more schemes to legalize criminal
proceeds if you type in the search bar
the phrase bollywood money laundering
you'll find some interesting and
sometimes outright frightening schemes
that are used in indian cinema
[Music]
hollywood accounting is an already
well-established term that describes
complex and opaque schemes reducing
taxes recalculating profits and
inflating expenses
and thanks to the ability of financial
consultants unprofitable films can bring
their creators very good money and
leading pictures the opposite as a kid i
loved harry potter i mean who didn't
right
my favorite movie was actually harry
potter in the order of the phoenix but
can you imagine how surprised i was when
in search of material for today's video
i came across this document
now if this is true then the film which
grossed almost a billion dollars
bought warner brothers losses of 167
million
to be honest i really don't want to
believe in such a scheme after all i'd
love to see real magic in hollywood
movies and not tax evasion schemes this
is
a lie it's not a lie i saw it but i
would like to draw your attention to
another issue
what do you think which branch of the
economy in the coming years may be the
locomotive of money laundering
in which industry are unrealistic
investments concentrated and the human
factor becomes critically important
where can one person's mistake cost
hundreds of millions of dollars
of course this is i.t
but in my opinion the market situation
has changed significantly in the recent
years the recent collapse of theranos
the scandals with google and meta make
fraud and high-tech companies
not so easy as one would first believe
regulatory and tax authorities keep too
much of a close eye on them
but there is a sub-sector of it that has
budgets comparable to hollywood film
studios but at the same time doesn't
feel the pressure of inspection bodies
i'm talking about the development of
computer games
translating into common someone [ __ ]
made off with nearly 20 tons of my gold
and all the lighter stuff and you
you can be the judge right the budget of
cyberpunk 2077 was 314 million dollars
wake the [ __ ] up samurai
we have a city to burn
now this is a number comparable to
blockbusters such as avengers infinity
war or pirates of the caribbean at
world's end the game failed massively at
its launch and subsequently brought down
cd projekt's red shares and received
only 68 on metacritic so what did a huge
scandal break out followed by an
investigation of financial activities or
mass complaints from investors
no
it's just that something didn't work out
for polish programmers things happen
similar stories actually happened with
gta the trilogy definite edition no
money no funny bunny honey anthem and
bloodlines too and even battlefield
2042.
don't you think that game developers
would face a whole wave of high-profile
financial revelations in the coming
years i'd like to be wrong but for some
reason the situation in game dev reminds
more and more of that sort of tax fraud
riddled history of hollywood
well anyway my name is bradley and
thanks for tripping with me on this
teeny tiny topical and tropical
telephonetic tenderhearted trial through
the tantalizing fantasizing intense twig
escapes of the online jungle i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you